[Music]
[Music]
guys and a new rule effects and today
I'm gonna learn how they make breakable
props for movies and TV shows let's
check it out
from sinewy bones to fake blood to fake
weapons new rule effects provides
Hollywood with all kinds of props and
effects but there's one thing they truly
specialize in breakaway props and
effects the kinds of products you see in
a movie that are meant to be broken this
is ryan johnson he's the owner of new
rule you've seen new rules work in many
places before the FX studio showed us
how breakable props are made when and
how they're used and then they let us
put a few of their coolest products to
the test it's like getting hit with like
a nerf bat or something
[Music]
to make a breakaway prop they take an
actual object like a glass bottle and
create a mold for it a very hot resin
plastic material is used and is then
poured into a negative after either a
few hours or even a few days they'll
have a hardened final replica that is
light and meant to be broken
other objects like chairs and cinder
blocks are vacu formed and 3d printed
but why do they shatter so easily they
they break very easily because a they're
very very brittle and they have a very
weak molecular bond so the molecules in
the substance are very very weak and so
it breaks very easy on any kind of
impact this stuff is designed for
absolute safety the level of safety
that's required on the set is determined
by how the prop is going to be seen in
the film if it's a bottle that's being
broken over a head for example we have
to make sure that the the resin is thin
enough so it'll break easily and safely
we'll engineer the prop so that it
performs in the way that's specific to
the script and with that we are ready to
try a few of these out
[Music]
you know breaks like a bottle as well
have a heads-up next time on that okay
heads up I gotta say like that doesn't I
mean I barely feel the impact yeah like
like if you have a ring okay if you pop
it man first it'll just literally fall
apart okay we don't even have to squeeze
it that hard but I just
so I look look look look if like I'm
looking at this and I'm like this looks
like glass like I'm still kind of like
afraid to touch it so for a big
breakaway window effect what we usually
tried to do is actually a lot of smaller
panes that are all glued together into a
balsa wood frame this might be for a
scene in which a character might have to
punch through a window you have to be a
little bit careful when you're using
breakaway glass especially with the
larger pieces because they are gonna
break in really sharp shards but if you
just punch like straight through it it
would break now first scene in which
something much bigger than a fist like a
full body or even a car goes through the
glass that window will be made with
tempered glass which will actually be
shattered a fraction of a second before
anything actually goes through the glass
with the help of a pyrotechnic device
[Music]
all right now go get me the fake one no
that wasn't bad at all it shows it looks
like a big salad brick was actually like
a hard sponge but that's ridiculous I
like this is cool
[Music]
household products like plates mugs and
vases can also be made to be broken now
there are a few other tricks to make
convincing breakable objects sometimes
they'll use rubber glass shards those
can be used in a scene where a character
has to walk over glass die hard I tell
everybody slow down let every let the
camera capture the action so if you go a
little bit slower you ended up what you
end up with bigger shards so let's slow
a few of these down
I really enjoyed smashing things and
breaking all the bricks I learned that
as difficult as they are to make it's a
lot harder to make something that
breakable it also looks realistic but
there's just something so satisfying
about breaking a bottle or a brick or a
chair there was a childhood fantasy come
true
[Music]